today's report is damning could it have
been worse with the original findings
softened up prior to release Congressman
Jim Jordan as a Republican represents
Ohio he just introduced a resolution
calling for the DOJ to release more
documents on the decision-making at the
FBI in 2016 he joins us tonight
congressman thanks all for coming in bet
you suspect this is not all there is no
we've been asking for all kinds of
documents we've caught him hiding
documents how about the fact Tucker that
we've seen all these text messages
thousands in fact the Attorney General
said there I forget 50,000 text message
between struck and page but the one most
most telling was the one that says we'll
stop Trump we don't see that one till
today so yeah they haven't complied with
subpoenas from chairman Goodlatte
subpoenas from chairman Nunez we've
caught them trying to hide information
from us they kept this text message from
us until today so of course we want the
information so we can do our job and the
last thing I would say is just remember
it was a couple days ago that we learned
that rod Rosenstein who in essence runs
the Department of Justice right now was
threatening staff members on the
Intelligence Committee so when you put
up together of course we need a
resolution saying give us the
information so we can do our job and get
answers for the American people
so unidentified FBI lawyer number two in
this document is quoted lamenting the
fact he didn't try harder to get Hillary
Clinton elected and bragging about
himself as a member of the Trump
resistance anti Trump resistance it he
goes to work from Muller why don't I as
a citizen have a right to know who that
isn't what he's doing now
I agree with you we in fact we tweeted
out today who is lawyer number two we
want to know because lawyer number two
just like struck just like Paige was on
the Clinton investigation he was the
lead lawyer the primary lawyer on the
Russian Trump investigation and all
three of those individuals Tucker went
on the Muller team we're obviously
subsequent off the team because of this
animus they had towards President Trump
but these are three keep it's
interesting the three people that come
over from the FBI to Mulder's team all
were on the Clinton investigation all
were on the Russian investigation and
all hated President Trump that's
interesting to me so yeah we need to
find out who this individual is and
bring him in plus what also is
interesting will stop Trump
remember when this happened this is a
text message from August 8th so Peter
struck opens the Trump Russia
investigation on July 31st
eight days later we'll stop Trump six
days later we have the text message
we've got an insurance policy to make
sure president if that doesn't show
where these guys were at I don't know
what does it tells you everything that's
exactly right congressman thank you for
that appreciate that thank you